Marsha is in Minnesota hi Marsha welcome
to the Dave Ramsey chef
good afternoon afternoon how can i hi
well I'm I'm 41 years old I was
diagnosed with Parkinson's at age 30 and
didn't think I was gonna survive much
longer mentally but two years ago I got
deep brain stimulation so I feel
motivated to get control again good and
I've got two boys
once the senior this year my other ones
12 and I want to not be a burden that's
my main goal to my kids so um and I'm
not many school debts or anything I've
got to Carlos but one of them I kind of
regret but I told that is with the house
it's 134 and with my cars it's 12 and 14
to dream cars and so you're saying mom
why do you have to card debts well my
second kid my older son is a he drives
work I'll show you when in debt to buy a
teenager car yeah okay and I had
regional spot uh with cash but it it
fell apart then so I tried the youth car
approached but anyway so yeah that was
my stupid gotcha
okay so what do you make a year I just
build these so I get thirty six hundred
a month so that covers all my bills but
I haven't I've got thousands of savings
so roughly it's forty four thousand okay
good
how much did you say you have in savings
thousand oh you have your one thousand
so you're getting started okay and you
have the - car - okay and your question
is if your question is about not being a
burden to them yeah and I put my kids to
school so I just I and I've listened to
your podcast about going into student
loan debt so okay well we don't they
don't need to go into student loan debt
for
sure yeah I don't either since I was
able to get grants scholarships so your
oldest one is a senior yeah what is he
thinking of going to college next year
he wants a good I told him to go to a
secondary at college like your bias you
can live at home under community college
yeah anyone come for nursing but I just
don't see him doing that he's very
mathematically so I can't work out his
generals first but okay here's the best
way to do that let's begin with a goal
in mind and then flesh out every single
detail of the goal and then you know
what you have to do to hit the goal okay
and so let's say he had a goal of
getting a degree from a four-year school
he's going to do two of the years at a
community college because it's cheaper
and then he's going to go to an in-state
state school which will be the cheapest
preferably one near you and you can live
at home all four years that way and
complete now you would want to make sure
that whatever Community College and
field of study he picks there will match
up with the degree he's wanting to go
and transfer those credits
over into the next college right so you
don't want to go take a bunch of stuff
at Community College and not match up
towards this four-year degree where he's
going to transfer to so you can find all
of that out now you just do the research
it doesn't cost anything you get in
touch with the local state school find
out which community colleges match up
with them the best and then go to those
community colleges make sure you take
the exact classes that do the exact
transfer so that you can so that they
count for your basics there's your core
stuff your core curriculum stuff should
transfer but not if you take a bunch of
weird stuff and and not if it's from a
school that's not recognized by the
school that you want to transfer to so
you've got to do some work here
the other piece you'll get from this is
you'll figure out what it costs to go to
the in-state school in your area the
four-year school and what it costs to go
to the Community College now we have a
financial goal that we need to work
towards how are we going to get that
money to do that in your all's case with
you on disobey
as a single mom with two boys making you
know making $40,000 a year on disability
income only they probably are going to
qualify for Pell grants a no-brainer
yeah Pell grants are for you know
they're for folks with in at with income
issues and and you know with I think the
fact that you're on disability is
probably going to qualify them for that
so let's look at Pell grants and you
fill out a thing called the FAFSA the FA
F essay I can never remember the
initials but it's the federal paperwork
now be very very careful that none of
these people lead you into a loan
because some of them do grant sounding
things that sound like a grant and
they're actually alone but you're
looking for a Pell Grant remember that
phrase and so you need to go to that
both schools you need to make sure the
curriculums line up you need to get your
costs involved you need to find out
about Pell grants it's possible he could
do four years is there a four-year
college near you there's components of
nursing if you want to go for a nurse
and two-year associate Center for a year
is that not and said is there a
four-year college near you that's
in-state yeah there's Minnesota and U of
M that he could live at home dinkler
yeah okay you may be able to pay for all
of that and he may be able to go there
the whole time
with the Pell grants Pell grants may
cover it and so where do I find these
programs we're doing you go - there you
go - fine you go to FAFSA and you start
researching Pell grants online and you
fill out his FAFSA and you need to tart
start talking to the schools in the area
and they'll help you they'll have
guidance people there but in no case do
you need to get a loan under no
circumstances and I'm going to send you
a copy of Anthony's book today debt-free
degree and you read it and your senior
reads it by Monday and you get started
on this now you're late you should have
already been working on this he's
halfway through his senior year and so
you got to get moving here
and you're gonna have to it's all about
planning and it's all about details
that's what keeps people out of debt is
setting the goals that are
realistic and funding them then and it's
all about that and download that podcast
and both of you listen to it the
borrowed future podcast again the third
episode drops on Monday but the first
two episodes are out there and both you
and him need to listen to that you guys
need to get on the same page and need to
have a lot of talks about his future and
so what it amounts to is is what you
can't give him in money you can give him
in coaching and direction and motherly
motivation and you can give him all of
that and he won't have to have student
loans he needs to go take his SAT a CT
and and then if he doesn't do fabulously
on it he'll need to take it again
because most of these places super score
they use the best scores out of each
category from the various tests that
you've taken and so you need to go back
through and do that over and over and
over again this is very very possible in
your situation that this young man can
go to school without a student loan do
not take out a student loan it's all
about the planning it's all about the
detailing and it's all about pushing
through and this book will show you
exactly how to do it it's written for
you your who Anthony wrote this book for
and so I'll send you a copy of a
debt-free degree the step-by-step guide
to getting your kids education without
student loans folks it's just really
possible so here let me kind of walk you
guys through that are listening out
there let's say he gets no Pell grants
let's say she doesn't qualify I think
she does but let's say she doesn't can a
senior still get there yeah if he's
living at home the in-state tuition with
a typical in-state school today is right
around $10,000 a year ten thousand
dollars of years eight hundred thirty
three dollars a month usually repeats us
four or five six nights a week in the
rich neighborhood not the poor
neighborhood you're gonna make fifteen
hundred bucks a month delivering pizzas
you need 833 a month and in the summer
when you're not in school you work a
40-hour job plus deliver pizzas at night
and you pile up some cash to make
to make sure you get through school what
you want little Johnny to work yes I
want little Johnny to work most of us
that went to college worked while we
were in college it's hard to find an
individual that didn't work while they
were in college most people did this is
the first generation that is calling us
child abuse it's ridiculous this young
man can go to school debt-free see
somebody's just got to say it out loud a
lot and we can end this student loan
mess this is the Dave Ramsey show